Hello. Welcome. Welcome. Hi, Jennifer. How are you?
I'm good. And you? I'm very well. Thank
you. So we have just started streaming.
And
let's try and set a little bit of
background then on why we're meeting today and
what we wanna accomplish.
So we met up last week because you
had
a small problem that you wanted to try
and get over with TerraForm.
And I thought I could maybe help, but
we ran into a couple of challenges with
that. Do you wanna just add a little
bit of background on what you were trying
to accomplish?
Yeah. Sure. I mean, I have
and I contribute to a lot of different
projects and organization,
and usually, it's not that open when it
comes to managing the organization itself. So creating
a new repositories or
assigning new labels to
repositories
or adding new members and owners and teams.
It's something that you always have somebody to
to ping and ask because it's no.
That's how it works. But I realized that
there there is a a difference
a different way. There is a telephone data
provider that a few
organization use where you can,
yeah, programmatically
create a forecast and somebody can review it
and merge and the automation. Terraform itself will
make apply the change on the GitHub organization.
And I think it was it is a
good idea to be open in in that
as well.
And, yeah, that's why I asked you to
help me because I didn't know, like, Terraform
that well. And, yeah, it was a good
chance to
to learn something new.
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And we did manage to
get somewhat of the way. Right? So
using the the Terraform provider,
we were able to automate the creation of
our labels on a single repository.
We managed to use some of the new
features of HCL from Terraform 0.12 that allowed
us
not not to have to duplicate that resource
definition for each label we wanted as well.
So that was really cool.
But, unfortunately, the challenge came when you threw
that dreaded question at me of how
how can we create these labels on more
than one repository? And I was like, ah.
That's a challenge. You can you can nest
that you cannot nest for each, like, how
you do with code. So we we were
able to do a for each on the
labels, but we weren't able to do the
for each on labels and all the repository.
So that was, like yeah. That that's where
we stopped.
Exactly. Cool. Great. That's great great background there.
I think we covered everything. So what I
thought it would be cool for us to
do today is I'm also a big fan
of another infrastructure tool that shares a lot
of the same responsibilities
that Terraform does called Pulumi.
I know that you're a huge advocate based
on your talks of infrastructure as code. And
when you say that, you mean actual code.
So you you like to get your hands
and say go. Right? That's that's your children's
choice. So what I thought we would do
is is use Pulumi.
I'll try and explain the concepts as we
go for anyone that's not familiar with it
and why we're doing what we're doing. It
should feel very similar to Terraform.
The only the the major difference is is
that you use a real programming language to
do everything that we wanna do, which means
we have the ability to throw in loops
for whatever reason we want to duplicate the
creation of certain resources.
I'm gonna do this TypeScript because I'm most
familiar with that when working with Pulumi.
But assuming we get through this relatively quickly,
what I would like to do is then
just replicate one certain aspect of it in
Go so that you can see the comparison
of the code side by side and just
to show you that it works anyway. But
I don't I mean, I'm I'm a fan
of TypeScript because it's strictly typed, so I'm
good with that.
Excellent. Good.
Alright. So let's get started then. I'm gonna
share my screen.
Gonna pop over here,
and we should see that I have, at
this point in time,
a
almost empty repository.
So there is nothing inside of our TypeScript
directory.
So let's start there.
When I do this from the various scraps,
so, like, you know, nothing exists yet. So
we can see the entire flow as we
go from zero to everything with Pulumi.
So
Pulumi provides a wizard that allows us to
use a starting template to do a lot
of the boilerplate that is required to generate
whatever kind of infrastructure
that we want to provision.
So when I take Pulumi new
maybe I can make this bigger.
Oh, yeah. That's it. Okay. When I take
Pulumi new,
we can access to all the templates that
are available. So I don't want to do
anything with AWS or Azure or GCP. You
know, we're we're doing something slightly more unique
today. So I'm just gonna have to show
additional templates.
And that just gives you a list of
all of the templates and not just the
more popular ones. And what we can actually
see is that we do have access to
oh, okay. There we go. There's my arrow.
We also have access to packet templates, which
we'll play with another day. And so I'm
just gonna start with
a really basic TypeScript template where it has
no providers configured, and then we'll add on
the GitHub type provider
ourselves.
So we'll get this a name. We'll just
call this GitHub demo.
Description isn't important. The stack isn't important.
And this is the first thing which is
different
from Terraform.
So let me kinda cover this. Let's just
get it finished.
I
my
testing from earlier. Okay. So we'll start actually
from the scratch. I had some state saved
into my home directory with stacks that I
was testing the setup that I was working
on with. So I'm just gonna I just
blew that all away.
I'm gonna do a Pulumi login. Now the
Pulumi login is kinda like a back end
provider for Terraform. It's where do you want
to keep your state file? And I'm just
gonna use local.
That's all that means.
Then I will run new again,
but I don't have to run new again.
As you can see here, we actually have
the boilerplate there. It just failed to create
our stack.
So I'm gonna delete the stack file, which
is this Pulumi.dev,
and we'll create the stack.
And we
call it dev, and we've got to provide
a password. Now let's see. It's the second
major difference. The first major difference from Terraform
is
we're using a local provider, which I guess
you can do with Terraform. And the second
major difference is we're providing a pass phrase
or secret
to do secret encryption
locally
so we don't have to worry about providing
environment variables to pass in all of our
secret tokens.
Mhmm. I'll show you what that looks like
as we create our first one because we
we are gonna have to configure
the GitHub access token as well.
Okay. But let's see what we have just
now.
So
this is a TypeScript configuration which just sets
up some stuff for the TypeScript
compiler.
None of this is Pulumi centric if you've
worked with TypeScript before.
This file is just something that you write
once and hopefully forget about forever. So we're
not gonna cover that anymore.
We have a Pulumi.YAML,
which just has some metadata about our Pulumi
stack. So we just have the name and
the runtime that we're using. There are other
runtimes,
which is something that I really like about
Pulumi. And, hopefully, we do get to do
the Go stuff at the end. But,
although we can do Go and TypeScript, Pulumi
also offers us the ability to use the
dot net languages, which includes c sharp,
f sharp,
Visual Basic,
web I'm I'm sure there are other dot
net languages, which I'm forgetting. You also have
the ability to use Python and
something else. And so you you get a
good spectrum of languages, so you can hopefully
find one that you're comfortable writing. Mhmm. Then
we have our stack, and you can see
that because we're using the local login, which
means I've stored my state files on my
local machine,
It just does a little bit of configuration
around secrets and encryption so that anytime we
do add a secret to this file, it
will be encrypted,
and we will have to provide the decryption
password whenever we run a Pulumi command. This
just means we can actually really use Pulumi
as a GitOps tool because everything that we
need does actually live inside of the repository,
which makes this CI and CT integration stage
a lot simpler.
I see. So that's that's secure by default,
let's say. You can push that file and
that's it. Well, yeah. I mean, my password
is password one two three, so I'm not
going to push that because I say I
can anyone could brute force that in a
matter of seconds. But
if you were to provision or use a
really secure pass raise or something you had
stored in one password, yes, that repository would
be safe to store
and I see. A relatively public fashion.
That's not a challenge for any would be
hackers that are watching.
So
next up, we have our package dot JSON
because we are using Node. Js and TypeScript.
We just use the same ecosystem for distribute
in the SDKs that we need to consume.
So what I'm actually gonna do first is
just add our GitHub SDK so that we
can begin to provision GitHub resources.
If I check Pulumi,
GitHub, I should get complete. Yep.
And we can see that we're gonna use
the GitHub fader version one four two.
And we will just
well, we walk through the actual TypeScript code,
run a Yarn install.
So I was in the right directory. Yeah.
Good. Okay.
Next up, we have our TypeScript code itself.
So currently, the GARN install is running, which
is why we have the red squiggly.
But we're not actually doing
anything else yet.
So
let's import
our GitHub
provider.
And now we're in a position
where we can
create resources
in order to tell Pulumi to go and
do something for us.
Now that sounds a bit meta, so let's
just do this by example. So
anything that we assign to a variable in
Pulumi
will be created
as a resource.
So if I want to create a repository,
let's call this
demo repository.
We do a new
github.repository,
and we're gonna get this a resource name,
which is very similar to what Terraform has
as well.
So we'll call this demo
repository.
And I
I think I haven't used this guy operator
before, but all of the Pulumi
resources follow the very same pattern. Like and
Terraform does this too. It's that you have
a resource identifier,
and then you have an object which takes
parameters.
So inside of this object syntax here where
I have these curly braces,
we could just use the auto complete because
that's a TypeScript. We have all of this
information. That's nice. That's what I love,
having a Exactly.
Yeah. You you wanna be able to leverage
all that tooling we have in our IDEs
to make this as painless as possible. I
mean, like I said, I've not used this
provider before, and I I don't need to
know because my editor is gonna tell me
what I need to do. So That's great.
Yeah.
Let's give this a name.
We'll call this
demo repository.
Let's give it a dessert description.
Yep. So my demo
repository.
Here's my ID to clean that code up.
Let's just have a look and see. I
I don't wanna go through every variable. I
just wanna make sure there's nothing that is
Yeah. They also look similar to the telephone
provider as well because I see the auto
in it, the has issues, and all those
stuff.
So it looks familiar in the the term.
So it's really really funny that you mentioned
that. So this is the Terraform provider. What
Pulumi do is they actually actually build a
wrapper around it to analyze, like, the I
don't know if it's an actual ST,
but they analyze the guts of the Terraform
provider and then provide a Pulumi SDK on
the other side of it.
That's nice. Yeah. So
that's good. I mean, as people are like,
you can you can take advantage of the
fact that TerraForm has been around for so
many years and has loads of providers, and
people are always supporting it and using that
tool. So by adopting Pulumi, you you inherit
all of that as well, which is really
nice.
That's cool.
So I'm just gonna
we'll turn on has issues.
And that's it.
That's all I need to do to create
a repository.
Now because you do have some Terraform experience,
we'll just kinda cover one more thing, and
then we will test this.
The thing that we want to test is
exports.
So we'll say demo repository
equals
demo repository.
You're in there we go. So
what export style
why have I got a red squiggly?
Oh, no. Hold on.
Export
const
demo repository.
We'll get there. Alright. Okay. Cool. Squaddle's begun.
Whenever we export something from our TypeScript code,
are telling Pulumi that that is an output,
very similar to Terraform outputs. It basically means
I may wish to get this piece of
information from the state l relatively quickly
or or often.
So it just it's a little convenience around
that so you don't have to go through
too much. I'm just gonna pull out the
URN, which is the unique resource name.
Yeah. I think that's close enough,
which means that we can interact with that
outside of the stack if we want to.
I see. Okay.
Assuming I haven't done anything wrong,
we should be able to run up to
Pulumi app. Now we haven't configured the GitHub
authentication yet. I'm hoping it will complain and
yell at me and tell me what I
need to do for that to work.
So we'll enter our password.
Let's see. Yes.
Okay. So this resource requires to get up
organization to be set on the provider.
Alright.
So
let's see.
So there's a the concept of providers here.
I am hoping if we do GitHub
provider
equals new
get help provider.
What do we need?
Oh, that's not a thing. That's just auto
completing from my
there we go.
Okay. So we're gonna get this name. So
we'll call that Rawkode just because I'm using
my own account.
And we need a token
to cover in a second,
and and
organization
is optional. So we're just gonna skip over
that.
K. So now I have to inject my
token into this.
I have
not cheated,
but kept it hidden in a fail.
If I do get help talking p b
copy
and then go back into the directory,
What I want to do is now use
the Pulumi
secret mechanism and contact mechanism to set this
value. Provider config
set
secret
hub
token.
But, hopefully don't think it shows you this
when I paste it.
That would've been awkward.
Then you made a good job.
Okay. Now what I can oh, no. Maybe
I can't show you because I told everyone
my password is.
What we have here is just the secure
encrypted version of that string, which I'll take
away very quickly.
So I could commit this to get if
I was using the secure password. Okay.
And maybe we want to fill in this
token. I can't Pulumi makes this very simple
too. So we do config equals
new Pulumi
config.
Great.
Pulumi.
Oh, my auto complete is broken.
And config equals new Pulumi.
Oh, wait. Why is that a red squiggle?
And my provider is there.
Try deleting
and pulling it back in.
That's weird.
I'm sure that's the same piece of code.
Oh, it's a it's a typo, I think.
Oh, no. No.
So we could do config,
and then down here, what we'd say is
we require
secret.
And I called my secret
GitHub.
I think I called it GitHub token. Let's
just
yeah. GitHub underscore token. Perfect. Okay.
So we're pulling on the configuration,
which is a stack based configuration
from our dev stack.
We want to require the secret. If that
wasn't set, it would complain.
And, hopefully,
we now have enough
for this to work.
Okay. So I do need an organization.
So it's not that option? It's not that
option. Okay.
Can I be my own?
Assuming I can just create a repository on
my
oh, what's happened there?
I don't suppose you changed anything in a
dev file.
Okay. Let's just try
I'm set.
Pulumi.
Mhmm.
Right. I'll set it myself.
Equals
password.
Weird.
Right. Let's I got confused.
It's emotional.
Yeah. I
know how it works.
So
alright. Let's we're getting the same error again.
So this demo is not going very well.
This resource requires a GitHub organization to be
set on a provider. Now I believe I
set oh, no. Okay.
I do this all the time with the
Kubernetes provider as well. So
the problem is I created a provider and
didn't actually
use that Oh, you're be using it.
Exactly. So I wonder if I could probably
remove that organization,
and it would work.
We'll leave it on just now, we'll see
what happens. But
we have to tell it to use our
provider.
Yep. And then the R field.
Yeah.
So I could have protected all of this.
Right? Okay. Come on. We got this.
That's alright.
So how do we so
is there something I can provide?
So because this uses the Terraform provider, what
we can actually do
is just go check the TerraForm documentation
and see what requirements the repository
has.
So that needs an owner.
K. So let's set the owner.
Owner.
Weird formatting thing up.
I cannot set an owner.
Let's have a look at what this is
trying to do.
What about here?
Individual.
There we go.
And that's required.
Billion. So we're gonna say true
and not set the organization.
I think that's should be a
Logically, it looks enough. Let's see.
A smart person would have tested this previously.
Alright.
So That's why we do streaming.
The provider.
Yeah. We'll get there. I don't mind. I
don't mind looking silly. So provider config warning,
individual deprecated for versions later than 03/2000.
Absence of an organization already enables this.
It looks like forever race condition.
It does. It's not it's not gonna be
the best demo with the it may even
get past the first hurdle. Alright. I mean,
it's it's a it's a warning, so it
shouldn't fail for that. I presume it fails
from some some other reason. Oh, because the
GitHub organization is required.
Yeah.
Yeah. So it still says the GitHub organization
to be set on the provider. You know
what? I am very tempted
to just create a very quick organization to
get us past that problem, and then I
will work out how to make it work.
Yeah. I think you should do it.
And then we will file bug reports because
we are good open source citizens.
Alright. That's what we'll do at the end
of the stream.
Alright. So we call this Pulumidemoorg.
Let's put in my own email.
Personal.
Go.
Skip.
Alright. My organization is called Pulumi demo.
That organization will now live forever because I
will forget to delete it for the rest
of my days. So
I'm I'm assuming
we can maybe pass in a string here.
Yep.
Organization name to manage. Okay.
If individual is false, organization is required. Yeah.
That's annoying. Okay. Let's see what happens.
Ah, k. That's better.
Do we have a repository?
We do.
Nice. Okay. Nice. I mean, a bit more
complicated than I was hoping for for a
livestream, but we got there in the end.
Okay.
Let's
because this is okay. What I think what
is really cool. Like, I think we've got
a good idea of what Pulumi is doing.
So
rather than jumping straight to the labels, let's
show off one of the benefits of test
being in pure code. Right?
Because Mhmm.
We can
make this a function. This is my favorite
thing to do in Pulumi is
to take logic like this,
create
functions
which take parameters,
and
return
templated objects
like so.
So instead of passing in a hard coding
name,
we're gonna parameterize
this.
I'm not gonna bother with these for now.
We could template that course later.
And then just here
comes
create repo
demo repository.
And I can do that again.
We've got our output there. Remind me to
cover outputs before we wrap up.
But what should happen now is if I
run Pulumi up, we have managed to extract
core logic for both. We've managed to break
everything.
Yeah. I didn't I didn't give my that
I need to give it a title. There
we go.
Yeah. TypeScript keep me correct. So good.
Good job, TypeScript.
Yes.
Thank you, TypeScript.
Hopefully, what we see here is we're gonna
update one repository where we remove the description
and the
issues thing,
and we create another one.
So if we pop over here,
we have our two repositories
using the same block of code that we
you know, we extracted that logic and stored
it as a function, which I think is
really, really cool.
Yeah. And I think we it it's worth
to repeat the same, like, concept we made
for the last video that it's I think
it's important
to those kind of utility functions because they
had consist consistency
in terms of how our repository looks like
or when we will get to team creation
and, like, owners
and
maintainers,
you will have the same structure
no matter, like, who is opening up forecast.
I think that's that's very important as well.
Oh, yeah. Totally. Totally.
So
let's solve your problem from the last scenario,
and then we'll we'll Yeah. We'll wrap we'll
wrap this up. So let's say that we
want our create
labels,
and we're just gonna go straight into this
being a function where we have a name
and a color.
This is a function, and that's going to
return a new GitHub.
Oh, typing.
There we go.
And we want an issue label where the
name is name.
Oh, so because this is gonna be a
template resource, and we're gonna apply these labels
to multiple repositories,
that's with resolve and a name conflict on
the second repository.
So
we will come back to that in just
a moment.
But we'll give it a name, and then
we'll do color.
I will do name as name,
and
this is going to need a repository.
Okay. So that means we have a new
parameter.
So we're gonna create a label on a
repo,
and then we can use that template best
for guaranteed uniqueness.
So what we're actually gonna say is repo
dot name,
Repo
Oh, because that's the identifier
for that. So each repository would then be
a unique resource based on the repository and
the label name, which will Yeah. I see.
Because we see in the UI, we see,
like, labels with the same name across repositories,
but, technically, they are different, like, labels with
different IDs.
So that's why we need a different identifiers.
I see. Exactly. That has a lot of
sense.
So now we have a function called create
label
that takes a repository name and a color,
and we'll do exactly as we need. So
let's assume that we have
const labels equals an array
of
labels.
We'll
just do two. Let's not spend too much
time on this.
Color,
zero zero f f c zero. Alright.
But now we want to create these labels
on each of our repositories.
I could create another helper function that loops
over this, but that's just for the sake.
Yeah. That's that's all I have.
For the sake of quickness, which is the
label,
and this is going to do create
label.
And we pass in our demo repository.
We pass in our label dot name, and
we pass in our label dot color.
And then we can copy that entire
loop
because that's for demo repository too.
That's it.
That easy?
Okay.
So we do have a duplicate resource because
what did I mess up?
Repo name
name.
What have I got? Okay. Let's read this
properly instead of scamming. So
duplicate resource here and Pulumi app demo, issue
issue label,
call to string on an output.
Right.
Got it.
So there is a
that this this is really weird thing that
happens in Pulumi and that and when you
want to use an output, which in our
case, this repository is a promise.
So this value that create create repo returns
is a promise to a data structure that
represents a repo that doesn't actually exist
yet.
So when we pass this end,
what we actually need to do is build
in the ability to wait for that promise
to resolve.
And we can do that with coming down
to here,
what we can see is download repository
dot
I could apply.
Yeah.
That's where my JavaScript skills starts to
fade apart.
Yeah. That would be a that's a Pulumi
output. Right?
The gap repository.
Why is it not giving me the auto
complete, I would expect?
Oh, plus three.
Ah, yeah. Because we want the name dot
apply. Okay. And that's going to get me
a name, which can be used instead of
a function. And then
so that's just I know this is difficult
for
anyone coming across us. It's just not familiar
with how this works. But because this doesn't
exist yet, what we're saying is when this
name is available,
we want to then apply a function, and
then those functions will create the labels for
us.
And we can Back in the day back
in the day, I worked with in the
UI, land with Angular. So I I I
remember, like, promise, like, concept, but it's not
fluent with it anymore. So but, yeah, I
get what what we are doing. It's fine.
Alright. Cool. I I presume for people that
knows JavaScript work better than me, this is,
like, what they do all day. Almost like
I do with f. Like, if error equals,
like, nil, and I I error handling in
Go. So everyone Okay. Is something.
Yeah. For sure. In fact and, I mean,
if anyone is watching, that's going I still
don't get it. There is a great documentation
on the Pulumi programming model.
So you can just search Pulumi programming model.
If you click on inputs and outputs, it
talks about what is actually happening
under the hood there. Okay.
So if we run this again, we shouldn't
have been in a position where under no.
Come on, Pulumi. Be nice to me. So
what have I got wrong here?
Oh, because I'm not pass oh, silly me.
I'm passing and then the output instead of
the name.
Alright. Okay. So that just means I have
to change this function to no longer take
the report. I think you you have to
set the type of the name argument in
the apply function.
Maybe correct. Yes. So let's just quickly get
this function signature right.
So now we're no longer passing an output.
Although, that's another point. Another way I could
have done that. Well, let's talk about that
in a second.
So
because that's an anonymous function. I I don't
think it's gonna because it
and care too much about the type and
it inferred that from here. Okay.
If I if I did want English
failure.
If I did really want to pass in
the GitHub repository here
instead of handling
the promise further than than
the stack there,
I could have used Pulumi dot interpolate here
where I request the value, and that's a
magic function that would have resolved that promise
for me in lane. So I could've
I could've done that.
Which actually probably would have been a bit
nicer, but now that I've kind of committed
and done all the other code,
we'll stick with that. So
we're gonna ramp it up.
I wanna see a nice yep. Good. We're
now gonna create those are we're gonna create
some green.
That's red.
Oh, that's red. The provider.
So
let's quickly fix that. Provider.
It's a GitHub provider,
and I'm gonna copy this code. So you
can set the default provider programmatically.
I don't remember how to do that off
the top of my head. I'm not gonna
try
and guess it. So we will just set
it inside of that function.
We run yes. It's gonna give me all
my labels.
No.
Okay.
Validation failed.
No. I'm not sure if I can fix
that. That looks like an actual API error.
Yeah.
I just get Oh, the barcode. I think
the no. I think it's the color
that is not well defined.
Do you think it wants that off?
I don't know. Let's let's take off the
hash. And if that fails, I'll try red.
Oh, I think Jannica got it.
Well done, Jannica.
Yoo hoo. That's why I'm here.
Alright. So let's
pull up our demo repository
and
So issues label.
Yeah. Let's enable You can look at the
issues from the forecast. You can look at
the issues from there. Just click in there,
and there is a label. Yeah.
Ta da. Oh, yeah.
Nice color. That works.
Yep. You can tell I'm not a designer.
Alright.
Okay. Final thing. So we temp we create
a function,
and we can duplicate whatever labels we want
across all of our different resources.
And we have our stack
output,
which is just like a Terraform output. Obviously,
with with the GitHub example,
there's not a lot of useful information that
we want to make available to other scripts,
etcetera, but, you know, the outputs do the
exporting does allow us to have access to
these outputs.
And we can get that through JSON as
well. I think the problem is JSON.
Perfect. Oh, I see. So we can pipe
technically, we can pipes,
like, stuff.
Oh, yeah. So I could do the demo.
And if that was creating a, like, a
GCS bucket or an s three bucket or
anything like that, then I could then, you
know, grab that resource and use that in
another script by using j q and a
bit of j JSON wrangling. So Yeah. That's
that's cool. And these outputs can be consumed
by other Pulumi modules in the same way
that Terraform modules can do that as well.
So if you write, like, a core infrastructure
repository that spends up a Kubernetes cluster on
JKE and exposes a cube config, you could
then use that cube config in other repositories
by consuming
that shared x output state as well.
Alright.
So that's Pulumi. Any thoughts? Let me jump
back over to Rawkode.
I I think it's one one of the
reason about why I never tried it is
because I really never never looked at the
an at the code for it.
And I thought it was, like,
you know, a lot of codes to
that had to be right. I didn't know
that it was reusing, like, Terraform providers,
or I presume it to reuse the s
h u the Amazon SDK when it comes
to,
you know, interact with a cloud provider. So
I think it's yeah. In in this sense,
I think the stability is, like, guaranteed by
the fact that it used, like, underlying components
that are
solid and used by, like, everybody in the
world. So
that's that's cool. And yeah. I mean, I'm
a fan of, like, using code. So I
think that brings me the joy of my
ID or my, like, VIM setup with infrastructure
as code that usually is a pain full
of YAML and JSON.
Yeah. I mean, I also like
I does it work as the like, has
has Terraform?
So there is no concept of reconciliation,
like, CloudFormation or other, like, tools we may
have.
Or
Yes. There I mean, there is. So it
uses the Terraform modules and to understand the
resources, the inputs, and outputs, but it handles
all of its own reconciliation,
state management, etcetera. So it will do its
best job scenario. In fact, when you run,
like, a Pulumi
preview,
that's actually only giving you its best guess
of what it thinks it has to do,
and then it does it looks up the
current state at applied time and then tries
to work at what it has to do.
So there's a whole bunch of other stuff
going on that I'm probably not knowledgeable
enough to actually talk about.
But it works really well for Kubernetes as
well. It does not use the Terraform Kubernetes
provider. They wrote their own provider for Kubernetes
to understand CRDs
and can actually do and flight
programming logic. Like, if you can imagine you
want to update a deployment on Kubernetes,
you can have Pulumi do it, monitor the
stats from influx DB or Prometheus, and then
roll back that deployment of it as it
going to the way you're working because we
have the ability to use actual code and
and play computation, which is really, really cool
as well. Maybe that's a session. We could
do another day again. Yeah. I mean, I
I have I have another question. I think
it's the last one. But how
how often we
like, you saw or, you know, people mixing,
like, proper like, code that is not Pulumi
related
with, like, Pulumi code?
Is it common to use, like, I don't
know, templates? Is it I'm speaking in the
in the go, like, land, but there is
the same in the
in the in TypeScript, I'm I'm sure. But
if you if I have to, you know
maybe I'm creating an issue, and I have
a user, like, a user data to inject
so I can template it and call it.
Then how far I can go when using,
like, traditional libraries
that are not Pulumi related?
Let me show you something.
So Please.
We are obviously short of time. Jen, look,
and I do have a call. But Yeah.
That question was unplanned,
and I feel like I have to show
him something there. So
where did I create this? So there.
Packet examples. Okay. So I've been working on
a packet example
to spin up servers with user data. Now
I am very appended to it with my
infrastructure's code as well. And as I have
user data,
like this Python script here or
this userdata.sh,
is I actually want them to live in
their own file. I do not want to
use template literals within Go or TypeScript because
I lose all of my formatting and my
my IDE features, like, complete. Right?
So because Pulumi is just TypeScript and and
Node. Js, we can actually leverage the entire
NPM ecosystem.
As you can see here, I'm actually pulling
in the mustache templating
tool,
where I load the dot s h bash
script and then interpolate it with the contents
of my Python scripts to inject into the
packet user data.
So you can see that we have this
Python,
We have the bash code,
and we actually just inject the Python code
into a cat statement to write it to
a fail on the disk at provisioning time.
And I still get all of my niceties.
I still get all my Python format or
my Python auto completion and stuff like that.
So
having access to NPM and to GoMod and
all these other things, I think, you know,
you can use as many of those tools
and libraries as you need to get the
job done in a way that works for
you, which I think is fantastic.
Yeah. That I think that's what I need.
So to to, you know, to be happy
again with my infrastructure as a code. But
I have to say in the last couple
of years, I really tried to avoid as,
like, as best as possible because I was
bored about that. But, yeah, I think that
this approach really comes to very close to
what I I
I was hoping to to see. So Awesome.
Thank you for that.
Well, we don't have time to do the
goal one.
So let's we'll set it to take time
next week or or the week after. We
can try and do this in Go for
the Tinker Bell repositories, automate all those label
creations, and then we'll try and write about
that as we go. Is that good? That's
great. Yeah. Definitely, we're gonna use this one
and not the the one we tried last
week because I'm more comfortable with this.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you very much for
your time. I hope the people that are
watching enjoyed that, and I'll see you all
soon. Yeah. See you soon. Bye bye.